[Musique]
à
pour
[Musique]
bon
oh
maintenant tellement témoin ne va pas la
remontée touchés se laisser faire en
fait faut y croire
à part peut-être pas ne pas y croire
tous les jours alors combien vous allez
chez roush f60
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'est passé immobilisé le
baiser il a attrapé la sauce bien
marcher sur l'eau et moi j'ai donné la
vinaigrette
c'est génial c'est une chance à quoi une
vinaigrette ben j'avais plantes
réunionnais est planté ils savaient pas
trop on ne redoute et comment tu l'as
fait mais il sait pas non plus alors
péri cochin votre droite
c'est normal son mari non plus n'est pas
là oui finalement il n'est pas venu
j'avais pas vu malade tombe bien c'est
pas venir ce qui a volontiers c'est
normal mon ami claude sarraute juste à
fabien benguigui avait dit dans la 6 3
j'en ai mais on l'aimé prie pour qu'ils
entendent mener de clausade aussi bien
tout seul oui vous allez peut-être
bientôt sun elle repartira seul da kg
hormis l'air très bien un peu loin parce
que vous avez la tête comme ça
guy lattimer paraît assez très bien fait
ma chance et bien c'est à dire à bord on
à laurent et perry après on à claude et
benguigui images pour qu'ils entendent
après on a ceux qui crient plus fort que
les autres jours à la mer et au thème
est enfin c'est pas mal donc le norway
mustapha biskri lesbien et clausade la
base c'est parfait mâchant tu as tout
franchement c'est très réussi
s'il ya vraiment rien à dire l'hôte a
rattrapé sa sauce voilà donc pour
l'instant tour est vraiment le mieux
attendons
[Musique]
vélo oui fait laurent richier mais au
quatrième
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
rajeuni à défaut on se dit quand même
aller mais alors notre ami match on est
fou notre image on qui travaille très
bien d'ailleurs qui sait que dans la vie
il faut savoir donner un petit peu ça
thierry ouais ça va jean françois piège
bon sens bonsoir soir laurent ruquier
com présente plus puisqu'il suffit
d'avoir france 2 il suffit d'avoir
france 2 pour pourvoir laurent riquet
cicéron vous savez pas que ça s'appelait
d'idées on n'est pas couché pas que mon
chien on dit on n'est pas couché
absolument l'or tu vois quoi la même
chose que toi
à la tienne manche est bon jean-françois
c'est pas dans la restauration vous
recevriez votre successeur avec autant
de rencontres avec le temps le sourire
pourquoi pas tu croit simon le ressens
comme ça nous et vous pouvez avec les
plus tôt vous savez j'ai parlé de toi
samedi dernier j'ai dit finalement voilà
quand on est animateur sur france
télévisions on a on peut écrire que
les noirs ont des beach pas comment on
peut mordre un style le pire c'est de
voter françois bayrou c'est le pire
encore éventuellement c'est qu'ils
puissent voter et car le pire de pire de
tout pire que brasseur
c'est pire que pété un câble il ya
travaillé sur le câble et white font
chier avec ségolène royal mais tout ça
n'est pas du tout soit un téléspectateur
mais tu es allé chez le ch et le
médiateur allemand
oui bien sûr mais c'est sont pas les
directeurs qui sont les téléspectateurs
contre l affût toujours ce moment tu
vois tu vois bien comment les élections
sont à l'esprit sécheresse vachement les
gens jouer donc oui il fondit où les
gens font un travail quand tu es un peu
à gauche tous les gens de gauche sera le
cas que ce qu'ils sont pour bayrou qui
sont content finalement en ce moment
nous voilà tu l'as vu le médiateur
scolaire non parce quand je réponds du
mois aux deux dans cette émission
j'étais au havre par téléphone son foyer
lequel il est à la rue les médiateurs
qui s'appelle mono et l'arrivée une
fille qui s'appelait mono qui posait des
questions et toutes les familles je
précise bien que je n'ai rien à voir
même si je m'appelle mono comme elle
avec cette téléspectatrice
alors me l'a dit au moins 500 le
médiateur il est super
si le médiateur fait des copains il a
lancé la porte ouverte à n'importe quoi
après des animateurs peuvent mort des
stewards et aujourd'hui oui je laime
bien jean-luc delarue mais j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il avait pété un câble ce que
l'on dit qu'il a pété un câble c'est
plus grave que ça quand même tu sais ce
qui est dit sébastien sebastiani moi
j'ai déjà pris des lexomil
j'ai déjà pris des styles note j'ai déjà
picoler mais ça m'a jamais mis dans cet
état là argens a fait dormir arrive on a
tous fait des conneries 10 mois dont
vous allez être obligé de signer un
contrat d'éthique alors tu sais ça tu
connais ma vie oui oui
mariez pas mon problème
ça va quand même passé un mauvais moment
de noël à bages et oui bagages et je
passais par un pas une étape de la vie
que tu connais aussi scellé perdre
quelqu'un dans sa famille donc
effectivement c'est un verre c'est
vraiment à prêter plus comme avant ça ne
changera pas dire qu'en fait en même
temps faire de l'antenne après un mois
de janvier ça m'a vachement va jeter
quand tu peux pas faire autrement que
d'être souriant et agréable aux
téléspectateurs ben tu te tu te forcent
un peu comme michel serrault qui a joué
la cage aux folles le jour de la mort de
sa fille c'est comparer non mais c'est
vrai c'est bastien dayer à jouer le jour
de la mort de son fils en moto les
tuyères on a beaucoup parlé de ppr s'est
construit que ça c'est la grandeur en
fait sérieusement je plaisante pas à la
grandeur de ce métier c'est ça quand
même c'est que les mecs
moi je me souviens je faisais des
émissions et mon père était la clinique
en train de mourir bien sûr et je
faisais des émissions et il fallait que
je donne le change tu vois pas ce que
toute façon les gens j'avais pas besoin
d'aller pas me plaindre
c'est assez drôle quand les copains où
les gens tu vas pas où ta famille ou des
amis que tu as pas vu depuis un petit
moment de te dise je te demande pas
comment tu vas tu va très bien je te
vois tous les jours à la télé donc les
gens pensent qu'on va aller on va très
bien non plus réussis pas bien allez on
fait de la merde parce que le pire c'est
sa maman je fais régulièrement tefen
géographe de temps en temps et c'est le
plus compliqué mais j'avais peur après
la mort de mon père que ma mère ça soit
plus dur que ce que c'est en fait et
elle a vraiment pris les choses avec
beaucoup de quoi j'ai passé à dire
qu'ils sont des exemples quand tu sais
pas combien de temps tu es parents vécu
en 150 ans voilà comme les miens et
paquet d'années coiffé fait là où tu
réalises forme de folie oui et puis la
longévité d'un cancer un couple
fusionnel pendant cinquante ans le jour
il y en a un des deux qui qui s'en va
comme ils disent c'est comme si on te
couper l'arbre à quoi tu vois c'est plus
du tout pareil on a du mal à comprendre
et à réaliser quand on a fait 25 ans que
ma femme alors
et toi alors ça fait combien de temps
maintenant lawrence 15 jours c'est voici
c'est vachement bien géré les saletés
oui c'est plus rigolo textes sont drôles
et puis s'attaque pas en fait tu
remarqueras qui s'attaquent pas au père
de famille tu vois tu remarqueras quand
même que jamel debbouze mélissa theuriau
voilà ça mes proches je ne crois pas une
seconde à cincy si tu crois mais c'est
pas que je crois que tu sais tout
tournant je sais pas tout il se trouve
que je travaille avec kader aoun qu'elle
potes de diamètre donc je vais appeler
pour vérifier oui c'est vrai mais il
faut tout revoir rien sur les photos au
revoir la question des pâquis baisse
ils sont même pas main dans la main en
fait tu sais quoi
je crois que jamel et toute cette bande
ont connue melissa à un cadeau de plus à
l'époque a été assistante elle faisait
des photocopies toi quand tu as connu la
gonzesse comme ça tu vois moi mélissa
theriau pour moi c'est eva peron mais
pour les gens qui ont bossé avec elle
moi ça m'est arrivé de flavie flament
banon j'avais clairement je les connais
il était stagiaire sur frau tu vois
c'était une petite gamine quoi on les et
flavie pouces soit toujours faire
attention à qui on parle dans ce métier
mais ce qu'on sait jamais ce que la
personne va devenir saint thuriau il
excite tous les mecs ils sont ils en
sont tous fois
bah ouais appétissant pour moi non je
trouve rien de plus ni mois que des mecs
comme moi je me souviens un jour je suis
pas bon juif qui maintenant c'est pas ça
je te dis pas ça un jour j'ai croisé
claire chazal
à l'époque elle bossait à france 2 je
les croisais dans un ascenseur de france
2 à l'époque antenne 2 et lui dit vous
êtes années 50 vous êtes un peu jean
grace kelly
vous avez pas du tout le look à la mode
donc vous allez être à la mode et dans
l'année quel suivi tout le monde a
flashé sur claire chazal aujourd'hui
pour les enfants mais à l'époque et
mélissa elle correspond à l'époque pas
pourquoi mais elle correspond à un
physique que j'ai envie de voir c'est
assez supérieu ça c'est vrai mais puis
elle a cette fraîcheur elle a un côté
les grenoblois elle sent bon les
myrtilles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu dois faire
[Musique]
oui allô oui au quatrième
nul ne peut savoir ce que tu avais juste
avant exact
[Musique]
je laisse ça n'est qui s'était fait tout
ça très bien
[Musique]
mais
bonsoir le maître de maison d accueil
sur le principe c'est rien même si
mairie alors besoin d pas là je n'ai pas
la ja tombe très bien et l'auto-poussée
pas d'une actualité le doyen jouer le
doyen de la bande
[Musique]
il faut que les tiers et son tour de
parole vous devez bien vous mme harel a
en ce moment là avec tout ce qui se
passe là quand même sagot la période
pour nous non ah bah moi c'est rigolo
les histoires sarkoz moi je m'éclate
c'est marrant comme tout en chine
l'année prochaine je pensais pour
support un peu chez moi
ah non quand même c'était l'ex travail
va y avoir les premiers mois du nouveau
président et sa du nouveau président ou
de la tu parles de béroul à j'ai
peut-être voter finalement dominique
voynet parce que voilà faut faire un
geste
l'eau est absente et de campagne comme
on n'aurait jamais imaginé qu est ce qui
s'est passé est ce que tu penses pas que
au mieux on fait peur oui parler si tu
continues à nous faire chier ne portera
plus d'émissions sur tf1 c'est si les
gentils et puis il va t'arriver un truc
toit puis c'est calme il alors il est
rentré la niche
il a réussi à faire venir tous les
candidats si ni son papier à c'est la
plus belle bêtise qu'il est fait c'est
bien sûr on n'a pas forcé à faire ça non
ça c'est quand même son dictionnaire et
il s'agissait déjà de cette retirer trop
tôt il avait aucun intérêt social et
avions là
l'immersion c'est de sa propre
initiative qu'il a appelé les candidats
à signer son pacte écologique
c'était la dernière des choses à faire
la santé de besancenot ce qui la gauche
pour les démocraties thierry de la
démocratie ça donc il faut le mettre
on a un pied dans la bouche ne fait pas
un berniche ont jamais fait ça à ce
pauvre et n'échoue étais tu fais un
bénichou au wawel à l'autre ils étaient
couverts il a fallu les choses changent
parce que c'est toi qui doit nous
apprendre le savoir-vivre et peinture je
te dise je sais pas ce qu'est né dedans
et franchement je pensais que c'était
jeu sexuel
c'est une petite boule chaude dans la
vie en général c'est un peu plus gros
mais bon j'en pensais mais je donnerai
des montres montre un peu ce sont là les
vraies sont là mais ça c'est pour tout à
l'heure je veux nous on n'a pas eu voilà
d'échauffement elle est tellement
malines
quelle belle en importe une moyen-orient
c'est ce qu'elle a fait elle avait fait
un business de tarte au bonbon quand
même les pit avait trouvé un brevet pour
le sel aussi exact c'était quoi
c'était quelque chose qui empêchait un
système qui a empêché le sel de
collègues mais dans les salles hier
quand il fait humide et tout ça mais
enfin maintenant on est plus sur les
émissions télé comme je sais d'accord
mais enfin c'est quand même énorme à 26
ans elle invente le truc qui empêche le
sel de coller nomades a un petit côté
géo trouve génial maintenant elle est
dans le business de mission à l'export
tout le monde en parle au moyen-orient à
gadji un gars une fille et drucker
vivement dimanche ça se différencient
manche c'est quand même extraordinaire
union libre
comme quoi ces [ __ ] pouvait jeter
n'importe quoi c'est pas exactement ça
ils savent à acheter les choses de
qualité alors je leur ai présentés et
taratata que je commence la semaine
prochaine
ça y est c'est vendu mais comment tu
fais pour trouver un allié arabe
et la figure toi que j'ai cherché j'ai
cherché et en bout de course j'ai pris
miss liban on va faire la faire tu leur
as dit l'audience que ça faisait dans la
data en france
non mais il sera foot parce que quand tu
fais tout le monde en parle au liban
mettant ont refusé cette émission est ce
que les gens qui étaient invités dans
tout le monde en parle au liban c'était
des gens qui étaient connues par tous
les gens du moyen orient
oui parce que je suis obligé dion ah bah
oui chaque émission je faisais venir des
gens d'égypte de tunisie d'arabie
saoudite du koweit imagine la
programmation celle des recherches que
ce que je l'avais sur tous ceux qui se
comprennent entre eux ab oui celle
avantages de la langue
il ya un type qui fait comme toi avec
les fiches il fait les cds comme ça et
il te fais ça et on va tout c'est comme
un citoyen chaque roumain coup chaque ou
mac
et franchement pas c'est pas pour te
lancer des fleurs mais ça a révolutionné
le talk show au moyen-orient parce que
c'est la première fois qu'on arrive à
réunir plusieurs personnes autour d'une
même table c'était quelque chose qui
n'existait pas il avait l'habitude du
face à face où les mecs là puisque nous
on savait pas c'est qu'en fait l'idée de
faire un talk show avec des invités de
tous les univers différents c'est
exister ça n'existait pas en fait c'est
à dire que aux etats unis ils font des
one to one david letterman gélineau tous
ces mecs là ils reçoivent une personne
et cette idée de mettre autour de la
table en fait c'est nous qui l'avons
fait et donc mais au québec c'est pareil
ça révolutionner parce que c'était la
première fois père ministre rencontre
est une chanteuse exactement et ont
marre et alors mon mari est malade
lui qui voulait venir vous parler de son
livre
oui enfin vivre seulement il a fait un
livre magnifique très sympathique très
drôle spermato folie inquiète notait les
champs alors ça parle d'un homme tu vois
on parlait de couilles mais ça parle
d'un homme qui a un qui se masturbe un
garçon d'abord ça commence par un petit
garçon qui se masque qui se masturbe
depuis son plus jeune âge et en fait
c'est une maladie qui l'a et plus ça va
plus masturber plus ça va mieux mais je
sois pas qu'on parle je pense parce
qu'elle fait les gestes
non c'est pas comme ça j'avais oublié
bon en fait ce garçon devient
masturbateur chronique et il est
complètement isolé mais c'est la vérité
c'est je serais dit et il se retrouve
deux qui sont isolées si si quand ces
disques avoir joué maladie non une deux
fois par jour c'est normal et donc ce
cet enfant devient adulte et il est
complètement isolé il vit seul
renfermé et puis un jour il découvre
dans une petite annonce qui lie à la
banque du sperme
il y va et là il devient donneur anonyme
évidemment et sa vie commence à exister
il a une je re quelques jours exactement
il devient travailleurs et de fait il y
va et machado et puis se fait licencier
au bout d'un certain temps on lui dit
non merci on veut plus parce qu'ils
n'avaient plus besoin il avait du stock
ça suffisait la banque du sperme le
pouvoir de dire jouer
quelle est la morale du livre la morale
du livre c'est que est bien dans la vie
il ya toujours un espoir
en fait la moralité c'est que si tu
branle rien il ya aucun ça fait très
bien
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
à
il a même entonné diallo c'est lui ou
moustapha clos il n oui au quatrième
d'accord a tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention voilà convenu
ici nous sommes
[Musique]
bonsoir débarrasse moi je veux rester
comme ça parce qu'à ben oui notre lente
au jeu ce soir là à ses côtés à ces
claude sarraute quoi tout s'arrose
seulement j'ai raison de la grève est en
fout pas mal non ah ouais tu lis pas
voici on vous avait dit que j'étais avec
les animatrices de télé et puis de temps
que j'avais envie de manger ici et je te
jure
pour moi c'est une solution maintenant
le problème c'est que ce soir c'est un
dîner spécial porte tu tombes
depuis que j'ai réussi je mange du porc
ça c'est pas bien non c'est des
conneries smic
qu'est ce que c'est que ça et tu ne dis
rien c'est cacher se sont passés à la
cabane à me tuer tu manges tout bien
comme ça elle tue d'un coup tu ne fais
pas un bénichou tcc du foie gras liquide
dans une boule chaude c'est oui ah ouais
bah non le foirail où je vais aller en
enfer tirer une première rencontre je
trouve ça allait mieux se passer
excuse moi aussi ma mère qui va être
magique contre toi et surtout pas bah
oui je sais je risque d'avoir les
sarthois contre moi c'est toi que j'ai
du bois gr 1 mustafa nom me fois grâce
et à l'alcool
problème aucun problème c'est même moi
je te paie n'a alors maintenant qu'il
avoue fait ça jean-françois une tranche
de gens trouvent ça va il est pas trop
méchant avec toi nuit je les attaque 1
surtout quand tu me taquine sur mon âge
ça c'est pas son style
o o se passe on sait pas son style à lui
non il ne faut pas attaquer sur
l'intelligence sur la beauté tu as tout
donc être attaqué les gens sur leur âge
moi qui commençais de kamaz et
maintenant je trouve ça ridicule c'est
un truc du d'anti m'éclate à tout tu te
donne le bâton pour se faire battre au
ciri suis désolé si toi tu te la
raconter des histoires de dentier mais
je veux te dire la vérité j'ai un truc
ici qui tient de la colle j'ai jamais eu
autant de courriers de gens m'ont vu
passer chéri qu'est ce qui me disait
quelqu'un ou quelqu'un de 21 ans qui
fait plus vieux quand même fait beaucoup
plus sans déconner j'ai bourlingué ma
petite perry c'est bien là où il est
tellement longue et moi je viens de
tours vécu faire chialer du monde la
whey je viens de tours et je suis arrivé
à 17 ans à paris avec mes petites
économies tout ça et je suis je suis je
suis sur scène depuis que j'ai 15 ont
fait j'ai commencé très tôt donc voilà
j'ai 21 ans j'ai déjà je peux dire que
j'ai 6 ans de carrière vous êtes connus
comme en lan 6 et si on peut leur
raconter un mois j'ai à faire je n'ai
fait venir à la radio sans voir son
spectacle
et puis après j'y suis allé pour mieux
comprendre ce que je pouvais ce que je
pouvais en arrive à la radio commencé
parce que j'avais vu un article dans le
parisien tu vois et j'ai envoyé paulette
couderc une de mes assistantes aller
voir son spectacle à mahdia où il s'est
très très bien
et puis je les fais venir la radio mais
j'ai pas été coupée je ne peux je peux
le dire et tu peux le dire et pas été
convaincus tout de suite et je trouvais
que ouais il avait la tchatche n'était
pas malice la joie était à l'aise
qualcomm
mais que ça suffisait pas qu'il fallait
quand même qu'il fasse rire et je lui ai
dit quoi très vite et puis et puis j'ai
arrêté
[Musique]
et voilà c'est quoi ce brass les traire
sept manches et tu sais quand tu es mon
ami samuel benchetrit
mais c'est suite à une soirée des
personnes que je tombe du restaurant est
clair que l'art oui oui monsieur
benguigui loisel de clausade oui au
quatrième jeu pas enlever des points
j'espère qu'ils sont des chiens
donc c'est très bien je pense
l'ascenseur vaches super g lot tant que
ça va très bien alors les censeurs je
pense va lâcher ont besoin de prendre
vos vêtements
donc j'aimerais bien que personne ne
meurt ce soir non mais vous êtes les
derniers mois soulignent que les
habitants chose comme ça c'est vrai moi
je me déshabille ray un peu plus mais
tout à l'heure pour jean mène donc
[Musique]
mais chez norbourg soit fait trop mais
bon on passe à table à écrire
on
[Musique]
alors
oh
ces jeunes viennent au nom j'aurais aimé
du piano gerra absolument pas
c'est jouer du piano si j'ai du piana si
jolie piano à toi si je vais du piano
c'est jouer du piano
si jolis pieds noirs j'ai très mal comme
ça je le sois pas rien je vais juste bu
et improvise un tabac
est ce possible cet effet
c'est pas bien de tous les autres
machins oui il ya un feu mais oui encore
il y avait eu absolument tous les jours
ici voilà regard d'un nouveau feu un
nouveau feu ouais c'est se le dire à un
nouveau feu bon asseyez-vous mes enfants
un nouveau feu
commence
as alors ce ce changement d'équipé ce
passage de paris première en france 2
avec laurent fasse bien non patron ça va
ça va très vite on est vraiment vraiment
bien comme téléspectatrice électro
julien a donc encore après c'est vrai la
semaine dernière pour mener ce récit
cette jolie blonde est ce qu'elle est
parce que je dis abbey la tva temps bien
gym il ya un truc est clair c'est
qu'avant de savoir ce que tu annonces
poivre d'arvor tu dis qu'il ya une
cravate à pois ou une cravate arrive
c'est la télé c'est avant tout le look
bien entendu tout le monde se fout de ce
que tu dis en général c'est ce qui est
important déjà c'est la gueule que tu a
commenté sa paie toi après mais leur
toit naby en noir depuis tant d'années
qu'on fasse attention à ce que je dis
pas ce jeu comme ça au moins les genres
les gens les gens disent pas il a une
chemise bleue où ilan veston g dans les
news on avait voulu mettre un costume
alors soumise à rire avec un noeud
papillon
tu te souviens on allait acheter les
lunettes ensemble s'il y avait une
sacrée équipe dans les news je sais
quand tu réfléchis maintenant
franchement il est christophe alévêque
ouais isabelle mergault qui a eu à césar
comme didier porte qui continuent à être
assez méchant sur france inter je crois
qui d'autre que toi ya quand même de la
matière je viens bookeen qui est devenu
un comédien quand même émission été
arrêté à cause de ramadan puisqu'il
avait était arrivé enfin entre autres
choses il était arrivé avec une petite
bouteille de gaz sur les genoux à
l'époque des attentats mais trouve sa
tâche elle annonce pour y trouver de la
place dans le métro il ya pas de
problème avec une bouteille de gaz nous
ça nous avait fait de supers et hypers
que ça parce que je me suis ennuyée
porte avait fait telle époque où
intervilles reprenait animée par jean
pierre foucault et on avait fait
intervilles entre les serbes et
les croates étaient traités avec les
camps et tout c'était une horreur
c'était très mauvais goût et avec les
commentaires de foucauld dia veille
avait alévêque qui dissout tu te faisais
alors christophe alévêque vous occuper
de ce sport dans les news les we made in
on perçoit le présente bien le 20 heures
juste avant le 20h donc évidemment mais
je suis censé être honnête c'était fin
xd plutôt sympa nous en laisser faire ce
qu'on voulait pendant cinq jours et dix
mois jantes et c'est toujours toujours
au chanteur de mexico
non on reprend mois de juin entre congés
faire alibaba pour pour tf1 car oui une
très bonne chaîne d'origine échos
d'ailleurs s'il ya une journée de gym
est qu une journée est bien dans l'avion
de sarkozy la généalogie droite de
composition et toi tu fais quoi dedans
je fais le frère d'ali baba qui
s'appelle caciques et le très méchant de
ces faits le méchant méchant qui alibaba
gérard jugnot
il voulait prendre vraiment un oriental
pour le faire j'ai une amie qui tourne
là dedans leïla bekhti tu connais non je
parle pas assez jean lamas parlement
devlet des choses comme ça ne te connais
pas non plus un de plus qui s'appelle
lexomil à l'égard de ces six mois comme
je prends du stress avec de l'alcool je
déraille complètement si ça te fait la
même chose mais tout le monde à prendre
avant alcoa hallucine tu vois vraiment
des éléphants roses 50 arrive quelque
chose d'aussi désastre humain qui
collègues animateurs a peut-être fait
plaisir au fond de toi dans la partie de
son tour de table alors six ans dans la
partie claire aussi
ah oui je suis ravi parce qu'il est
tellement prétentieux et tellement
méprisant avec les autres est tellement
désagréable que quand il se fait choper
ça me fait plaisir mais dans l'absolu
c'est pas un mec de la soutient terry
pardon il est tu peux même pas dire
qu'il soit prétentieux quoi que ce soit
on ne le co n'est pas autre part la
personne ne connaît pas non pas être
solidaire avec quelqu'un qu'on ne
connaît pas plaidé
quelque chose à michel drucker qui n'est
pas un ami par exemple mais c'est
quelqu'un avec qui on a des relations
fraternelles français mais jean luc
delarue gens diraient ni du bien et du
mal puisque on ne le connaît pas ça on
peut pas dire autre la gîte sur les
plateaux mi6 qu'on peut lui reprocher
par exemple c'est que ils nous appellent
toi non je ne sais combien de
ils nous harcèlent dans le téléphone
même parfois pour qu'on participe à ces
émissions pas seulement celles qui
présentent mais celle qu'il produit où
ils nous demandent de prendre untel
untel untel
en revanche lui on supplie de venir sur
ne serait ce qu'une fois sur nos
plateaux tu l'as où tu vois déjà nommés
ci ont jamais moi non plus donc si tu
veux il peut pas demander une solidarité
de la part des animateurs alors qu'il ne
les fréquente pas et qu'il n'est ce pas
et qu'il ne les connais noir clairement
il est papa camara connais pas non plus
moi je suis désolé on demande à duhamel
de partir parce que effectivement il a
dit dans une enceinte privée qu'il
allait voter bayrou est quelqu'un qui se
font porter pas pour la première fois
très mal d'être avec les personnels et
qui passe voit comme mort d'un steward
touché sa des gonzesses est moins grave
que voter by hommage dans match tu vois
que de la rue une fois qu'il est ce la
peur de l'avion donc c'est pour ça qu'il
prend du stilnox les familles une fois
qu'ils étaient lus les hommes et une
fois qu'il est en libye il est dans un
petit avion et tous les jours il change
de look
si tu as vraiment peur de l'avion tu vas
pas y a rien de plus dangereux ce petit
avion dans l'article 10 qui prennent
l'avion plusieurs fois par jour je suis
d'accord que ce soit grave de voter
bayrou très grave très bon mais
franchement un animateur sur le service
public qui se comporte comme ça et qui
ensuite va faire des émissions
compassionnel sur les problèmes des gens
je suis désolé si nécessaire
alors moi vraiment ça me gêne cette
chasse à l'homme
un bon ben ça c'est leur sympathie pour
jeudi
c'est là où les bons c'est là où bin
hammam et non mais c'est vrai au fond du
court il a écouté tout le monde sait
muller il entame sa remontée
tu le sens me dire d'arrêter pourquoi
est ce qui serait sanctionné par france
2 c'est pas dans ses boulons quand même
qu'il a commis ce qui peut
éventuellement sanctionnés par la
justice comme l'histoire duhamel me
choque absolument
ce type est un journaliste au moment de
la de la campagne on lui dit ah non
parce que vous avez des opinions
politiques
un journaliste moi ça me choquerait
absolument pas de ppda soit de l'ump ou
au ps il a le droit de l'être
thierry c'est vraiment parce que duhamel
est un lâche je le dis que ils ne
protestent pas contre cette éviction qui
est absolument scandaleux il irait
jusqu'aux droits de l'homme
je pas dû compter en europe je sers pas
d'une inde accorde le droit les sources
en dévot comparer deux situations qui
n'ont rien avoir regardé un minuteur
texte politique c'est normal il est
patron de l'information je ne sais pas
trop de journalistes
je connais les
pignon de tous les hadjis tauriel
installations des visions et pas autant
je trouve normal qu'on me dise que chez
ruquier il faut pas que je fasse de
propagande pour tel ou tel un choix
d'ailleurs j'en fais pas les autres mais
on s'en fout
franchement mais cet idiot qu'est-ce
qu'on se fout de savoir que gérard soit
gauche mais c'est tout le monde le sait
qui va convaincre personne donc voilà
donc on ne voit pas il vaut mieux savoir
pour qui les gens votent que de ne pas
savoir à qui on va essayer de tout
influencé de façon insidieuse qu'est ce
qui est bien meilleur que de savoir
exactement pour qui les personnes vote
après tu fais le tri tu filtré tu crois
que tu veux bien croire et voilà ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que rtl si je
me trouve qu'on le remplace par gyllberg
un charmant garçon enfin dans tout ça on
le voyait quand même les idées
politiques c'est incroyable comme si
tout d'un coup on prenait une sorte
d'ange qui venu du ciel sans aucun doute
que bailly fois que vous engagez
gyllberg que lui amène peut être un bail
peut-être que voter bayrou c'est encore
dangereux pour certaines personnes et
qui les payent aussi je sais pas moi si
un homme d'affluence comme lui dit si
les gens d'ici duhamel vote bayrou c'est
peut-être non je suis désolé pardon mais
on aurait voulu servir françois bayrou
qu'on n'aurait pas mieux fait lorsque
franchement personne aurait relevé que
alain duhamel voter pour françois bayrou
et qu'il l'avait dit dans une soie et
dans un truc privé à sciences po
ça n'aurait pas fait une voix de plus
pour françois bayrou tandis que là en
revanche il ya plein de gens qui sont
dix ans dit donc dû la veille il a voté
bayrou s'est on pouvait pas faire mieux
soit les années fois que je t'ai vu que
j'avais un jules alors j'étais mariée je
suis toujours mari j'espère qu'il est
très beau il sublime
il sympathise avec toi je connais pas je
me situe la ville est menée dans ta
maison de campagne
ah bah bravo on voit comment je me
souviens par abeille est pas très beau
alors
vous allez pas voir ses veaux fond
d'écran battant voir faut quand même que
je précise qu' il est venu un jour il y
avait quand même déjà 100 110 ou 120
perd la fin de chatons c'est la grosse
cartouche de battes en bois rien c'est
une fois celle ci ils s'embrassent fenua
zoom du beau temps marié si thierry et
il a rencontré il ressemble un gros
merci aux seuls un jour du genre manssor
au mathis 50 pascal mathis on veut avoir
bu à ce qu elle a du charisme tout le
monde s'en rappelle
[Rires]
on va voir si vous savez répondre à une
question qui est dans le trivial pursuit
concernant claude nous permet d'entrer
trivial pursuit question comment claude
sarraute était-elle surnommé aux grosses
têtes ya un certain nombre d'années au
lot
non non en référence justement ces
expériences sexuelles ou de la madone
des sleepings parce que la crainte est
fait beaucoup l'amour dans les trains il
s'empresse à ses pairs du trophée pas
cessé dans le trivial pursuit mais
claude avait que robert puisse qu'il
aimait c'était picoler moi j'avais connu
à l'express à temps quand j'ai connu
rebelles quand il dirigeait l'express il
allait de bureau en bureau pour faire
ces mini conférences de rédac
il y avait un mec qui le suivait avec un
comme un chariot roulant comme un
chariot de petit déjeuner avec toutes
les bouteilles et revel s'essayer le
chariot ce gars est là et il choisissait
tel pinard comme la percussion et après
il ya un drogué qui ont été sous si à la
fin on lui avait dit si vous continuez à
bord vous vous pourrez pas vivre six
mois
quand on est sorti de l'hôpital on est
rentrés à la maison et avant de monter
on a une brasserie à en bas de chez moi
il est arrivé il ya des deux couples ont
la bouteille fêter ça y est il est plus
jusqu'au bout il aimait sol mais attends
je vais raconter je t'ai déjà
et à la fin il parlait très mal tu vois
il était vraiment très très mourant il
essayait de me dire des choses et parce
que avec jean rivard qui avaient la cote
c'est impossible il quelqu'un qui est
très beau et oui c'est ça très mauvais
alors je ne pense pas prendre ces
derniers mots qu'est ce que tu veux mon
chéri je suis désolé de te le faire
répéter mais je comprends pas ce que tu
veux dis moi ce que tu veux mon amour un
bloody mary mais en général les les
personnes qui aiment manger boire etc
les vrais plaisirs de la vie aime aussi
le cul non pas du tout tandis qu'on
pense j'aime ces quantités lausanne
assez logique est différent j'ai
heureusement perry qui doit choisir
entre la baguette et le beaujolais donc
tirer quel est ton choix la braguette et
je le dis que ça va être terrible pour
un homme de jean-françois recherche isr
si c'est pas le moment c'est c'est pas
le moment de décoller on veut baisser
encore un peu macho enfin moi je les ai
eu comme directeurs à l'express oui
voilà oui et c'était un très très bon
direct à sion intelligent sachons
reconnaître les qualités des gens ce qui
est agréable pas du tout à voir les
petites mafias je t'éclate besoin
non
et là commence à fait alors parce qu'on
disait tout à la porte avec une part
laissé nos parents quand tu as vécu
cinquante ans comme mon père et ma mère
c'est un brad pitt manque moi c'est la
moitié qui m'ont tous se retrouvent
quand tu as été un coup pendant quarante
trois ans que moi je suis tout seul
c'est très très très pertinent entre
jiechi qui est intéressant c'est de
savoir quelles sont les recettes des uns
et des autres pour être heureux après
tant d'années c'est ça
après tant d'années ah oui comment
fait-on pour continuer à être heureux et
passant après la mort de chant passe
quelque chose c'est ce qui intéresse
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je connaissais pas le pen et l'autre
jour pour la première fois de ma vie je
suis aller animer une rencontre entre un
petit club anglo saxons et jean marie le
pen
ouais première fois que je le voyais et
c'est quand même il produit est une
étrange atmosphère
il ya une espèce de virilité boursouflé
chez cet homme qui est gênant c'est très
bizarre chez le pen a passé cinq cents
signatures sache ça peut chasser
incroyable je les ai j'ai eu ce sujet là
cet après midi les habitants j'ai eu le
qg cet après-midi parce que pour mon
boulot je suis obligé thurman de sarah
c'est normal et il avait l'air quand
même
vraiment bien quand même qui fait dire
qu'il pourrait ne pas les avoir il ya
quelqu'un qui a dit ça dans l'émission à
la radio cet après midi je trouve ça
très bon indice c'est vrai c'est s'ils
commencent à payer des gens pour avoir
les signatures c'est que quand même
yvan du mal il avait déjà fait l'amère
peut-être mais prône pour en être à
payer pour obtenir une signature au 3 tu
les payes pas si tu es déjà aussi
facilement que ça c'est quoi nul moi je
veux dire que les mecs sont obligés
d'avoir 500 signatures pour se présenter
et en plus que ce soit public l'aimé
indices pour qu'ils donnent leur voix
mais y'a bien quand même 500 personnes
qui donnent des des signatures à l'appel
des maires ah non moi j'habite dans un
bled où le pen fait 20% est d'accord
mais tu comprends
ils sont cotés choix il faut que tu sois
dans 30 départements différents
alors déjà par exemple tu vois tu as un
endroit autant à plein temps l'aja
désormais oui mais tu peux pas les noirs
que deux heures trente départements donc
si tu veux c'est ça ça complique ses
fils jeu et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
n'entend pas parler de l'extrême gauche
qui fait des scores tout à cfm dans dans
les sondages pourquoi parce que les
tipis ram
il raconte que ça au lieu de faire
campagne c'est vrai que ça se passe
quand même un petit problème
démocratique alors je suis peut-être que
d'avoir seize candidats comme en 2002
c'est peut-être un peu beaucoup mais là
on est arrivé quand même au taquet où
s'étaient pas partout bon il y avait un
grand parti politique du peuple
t'expliquerai t'expliquerai un mec qui
viendrait de sirius mais kate au
deuxième tour des élections il a passé
cinq cents signatures il a pas un député
à l'assemblée nationale
le mec l'engrais c'est pas la démocratie
la démocratie est ce que c'est aussi de
donner la place à ceux qui ne sont pas
des démocrates alors tu vas me dire tu
vas me dire c'est aux électeurs de
trancher c'est pas seulement c'est à
dire qu'hitler a été élu au suffrage
universel est clair que tu as peut être
raison
voilà mais je pense pas qu'il soit jeune
fille clairement quand je vois tout çà
c'est tout dire
moi je suis pour eux que je suis guéri
françaises n'ont pas du tout panneau de
connexion
la vie politique française c'est
l'élection du crâne je le dis j'ai pas
encore lâché raymond barre mais je peux
aller j'aime pas les pgm pas les vues
j'aime pas les fans et je veux dire que
la connerie elle le crime le crime et la
maladie infantile notre république c'est
l'élection du président la république au
suffrage universel à ça parce que là
elle et lui apporte à toutes les
démagogies mais quand tu vois tous les
crétins que je rencontre dans mon coin
et qui te parle politique qui vont avec
toi au moins tu es un talent il faut
voter je veux dit ces gens ne sont pas
aptes à voter sur une bêtise il est
aussi important de mentionner la célèbre
phrase d'andré gide
oui arrivée d'andré gide je ne veux pas
voter parce que je ne veux pas que ma
voix est autant d'importance que celle
de ma concierge
oui mais non je trouve que c'est un
enjeu trop important pour le pot pot
pour lui les poules
non pour le substitut
mais la porte ouverte à toute démagogie
c'est ça veut dire que c'est sur les
élections à l'audience ce sont des gens
non le mélange l'élection du président
au suffrage universel plus la télé star
c'est un mélange explosif que le général
de gaulle afin n'avait pas prévu la
preuve c'est quand ségolène va toucher
un paralytique
elle prend cinq points donc c'est
portnawak dans ses portes non ce qui
compte c'est rare qui va être au
deuxième tour pour l'instant personne ne
peut savoir si c'est sarko ségo bayrou
le pen là on est sûr qu'il gagnera pas
deuxième tour parce que bon ça il y aura
toujours un barrage contre tout est
possible mais en tout cas à le faire
tout est possible d'ailleurs pas faire
ce sondage sur le deuxième tour cet
idiot on devrait faire des sondages que
sur le premier tour allons-y étape par
étape puisque deuxième tour
tout peut se jouer à partir du moment où
on a plus que deux personnes là il ya un
vrai choix qui se fait à savoir quelles
vont être les reports de voix si tu fais
pas un sondage sur le second tour tu
nous n'évaluons avec dans les ga les
records les personnes par le programme
alors que le sieur hakima gagnant qu'il
a appelée qui va téléphoner on ne parle
pas politique jamais arrêté de dire ça
trop content c'est une campagne plutôt
très politique avec deux choix de
société et particulièrement est ce que
les gens parlent de ses soucis mais bien
sûr je crois que je peux te dire qu'on
n'y a jamais eu autant de monde c'est
assez marrant parce que quand tu gauche
est candidat il te dit armé les sondages
11 c'est sûrement faut parce qu'il ya
tellement de monde qui vient
mais la droite à gauche au centre tout
le monde gilbert et des discours parce
qu'on veuille parler non pas forcément
pas forcément pour y faire passer pour
quand même resté une heure et demi à 6
écouter un candidat tory cités sont son
truc bon et les gens ils vont donc ça
veut dire que les gens quand même ça les
intéresse les émissions de télé font un
score pas pour dire que les gens quand
même ça les intéresse ici ils en parlent
ils savent très bien on leur a volé
l'élection 95 qui se compte c'est
intéressant les deux joueurs dominants
95 déjà on a on a été focalisée par la
bagarre ban a donné et on n'a pas parlé
de jospin et 2002 on a pu jospin du tout
donc su peu ça fait quand même
maintenant douze ans qu'il n'ya pas même
un vrai débat droite-gauche instant
installés dans le pays et là ils
existent eu d'accord il ya quand même
deux choix de société je suppose des
choix de société
je suis d'accord avec toi quand tu dis
que les gens sont beaucoup plus
passionnée par ce qui se passe sauf que
c'est important
oui tout le monde est concerné beaucoup
plus que les années précédentes parce
que le débat est beaucoup plus proche
des gens et d'asseoir des problèmes
légende des problèmes des gens
exactement c'est formidable mais je ne
crois pas une seconde que ce soit
aujourd'hui un choix de ce sens si je
suis pas d'accord parce que je trouve
qu'on vit plus longues années
précédentes
oh je ne suis pas d'accord au caire du
ciel si vraiment on a certes le site
émettra également devant nancy
segal et la question se pose est que tu
sens parce que tu penses que ça c'était
anglaise mais alors qu'est ce que tu
penses que la société anglaise est
vraiment différente de la société
française oui oui je crois oui je le
prends est ce que la société anglaise
est différente de la société suédoise
oui quand elle propose le modèle suédois
japonais
il faut l'assumer 1 c'est quoi si c'est
quoi là c'est quand même énormément
d'impôt beaucoup de solidarité beaucoup
d'exigences tous solidaires avec les
autres
après tu sais pas si vous avez vu un
sondage enfin c'est pas son daf et une
enquête de l'unicef sur les enfants en
europe où est ce que je les lui dans un
des rares journaux qui en a parlé
l'humanité dimanche auquel je suis
abonné mais bien à parade dans ce
rapport de que tu dors même si on ne la
recherche alors tu peux du chanteur de
l'unicem écoute irait on apprend que
pour la première fois ils font rentrer
d'autres critères que le critère
simplement économiques pour les enfants
sont ils heureux c'est à dire ont-ils
envie de se suicider au parrain
comptines des perspectives d'avenir
comment se sont ils dans leur famille et
on s'aperçoit que la pire des sociétés
pour les enfants c'est la société
anglaise société américaine pour la
société française n'est pas très bien
placé d'ailleurs de point de vue et que
les meilleures sociétés c'est
effectivement la société pays-bas et
pays nordiques et tu te rends compte à
quel point effectivement ne fait jamais
rentrer en ligne de compte dans les
comparaisons de société ces critères-là
soit géré alors tu nous fais qui au
premier tour moi je vote ségolène ou non
j'étais robert guéi robert hue ya cinq
ans et à droite a le droit de dire ça
battlefrance moi j'essaie d'appeler csa
j'essaie d'appeler france 2 pour savoir
quelles étaient les droits exactement
qui étaient les miens en tant que
chroniqueur dans l'émission d'oran et on
m'a dit de façon extrêmement clair la
chose suivante qu'à l'extérieur je peux
faire ce que je veux je peux évidemment
être dans un comité de soutien m'a-t-on
dit je peux évidemment dire de se faire
ségolène mais si dans l'émission de
laurent jeudi il faut voter ségolène ou
quoi que ce soit d'approchant alors on
déduira mon temps de parole du temps de
ségolène par contre s'il donne mon avis
sur autre chose
évidemment non politique aucun problème
et même si je parle politique sans
donner le sentiment que je soutiens
ségolène ce qu'on n'y a aucun problème
alors moi je vous propose si vous êtes
d'accord si tu m'autorise s'autorise de
pronostics justes
chacun doit marquer pour qui va voter au
premier tour
aux passants anonymes si vous voulez
voter blanc voter blanc ou un mini
sondage c'est absolument anonyme
vous marquez on fait le premier tour
aujourd'hui vous marquez pour qui vous
votez il ya aucun risque qu'on dise qui
a fait quoi
ségolène oui ségolène
évidemment j'ai peur
ségolène tu as voté trois fois sarko
sarko tu vois un comme co ségolène à
blanc à s'est pas encore décidé ségolène
mais tu vois que ces parts représentent
0 sarkozy à ségolène qui gagne
[Musique]
diallo oui bonsoir michael gregorio et
richard beaudoux est quatrième merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
bonsoir
sont invités ce soir
bon bah on parle je sais pas de ma
carrière au cinéma
ma carrière de chanteur ou ma carrière
d'humoriste du café de la danse
excellent 1000 r oui tu fais 1000 r oui
les faits c'était ma première fois parlé
la première voit parler c'était la
mienne alors vas-y vas-y ça donne quoi
bien ça donnait un truc un petit peu
comme ça mais bon c'était pas non plus
j'ai décidé de l'enlever finalement
désolé mais bon ça donnait un truc à peu
près comme ça mais comme j'étais plus
jeune j'avais encore la voix encore plus
aiguë et je pouvais c'était plus facile
de manier votre tessiture voilà
et assume son
[Musique]
à ses enfants
ouais
jazz
aux hommes
non
[Musique]
jacinthe un genre
j'adore obama
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
you
[Musique]
oh
grand
et hop
[Musique]
on
et
oh
non
[Musique]
oh
communaux
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
on a vu nos 4 et de l'accord
ce qu'il faut être extraordinaire
maintenant c'est si pour répond pour te
faire plaisir et pour me faire plaisir à
tous
laurent ce qui va te sortir c'est pour
ville
jamais un gardien on a professionnelle
ne va pas on va pas prendre à l'abattoir
ça va moins bien marché et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de nos latitudes
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou